oh it's fully frozen the disc won't come
out
this is not good i like computers a lot
i pretty much always have three at my
desks and that's not to mention the
smartphones vr headsets tablets and
other computing devices i have
throughout the apartment
i spend a huge amount of time on these
devices and i'm pretty much always
connected to what's going on in the
world
my friends via social media but this
week all that's going to change
this is the 1999 imac g3 and this week
it's going to be my only computer
i've already put away my laptops and my
desktop and i'm going to be disabling
everything by calling and texting on my
cell phone
so i will truly be disconnected
but first got to set it up with a little
help from someone from it
so basically um i got this this here
imac g3 from 1999 and this is going to
be
my only computer for the next like week
currently i can
only load like html one sites so i've
been to
google.com the html version
yeah man if you want to get anything
done this week you're gonna have to go
up to oxx
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
anything done no electron yeah you're
gonna need a cd
all right it's not gonna boot off of
your usb drive
i'm gonna be honest it felt kind of good
putting a disc in i haven't done that in
a really long
time
bad news um i put a disc
into this computer and now it won't read
it and the disc won't come out
i think i got it got it out
[Music]
look at this after eight hours
i finally have it running on osx
at least we have it in a point where you
can
maybe get on the internet good luck with
that
[Music]
it was weird waking up this morning and
not just like checking
my phone because that's what i would do
in the morning well i did check it and
i had no notifications because i turned
off everything today
i am going to try and start actually
working on this thing
maybe i should just see how the internet
works let's see if google maps works
[Music]
mapquest that's not functioning
how about buzzfeed reddit
will this work
[Music]
how about my email come on come on come
on come on
oh my god so i can get my email on here
i think i'm just gonna have to learn to
be more patient this week
oh it's fully frozen just trying to load
slack has basically brought this
computer to
a standstill so what i'm gonna do is i'm
actually just gonna send out an email
to all the people that i talk to on
slack and say
dearest colleagues
i am writing to inform you
that i have time traveled backwards
20 years i have to make a thumbnail
for a video that's going up this weekend
i've installed photoshop cs1
on this computer right here i'm going to
try opening this psd
oh my god reading photoshop format it's
actually loaded all of this
content this is a 20 year old version of
photoshop and the
document fully loaded without any
problems why am i paying for
creative cloud let's try putting in some
photos into this okay like this is a bit
slow but it's like
it is perfectly usable all right
i will send this out we'll see if anyone
can tell that it wasn't made in a modern
version of photoshop
[Music]
so it's day three and at this point i've
actually established a bit of a routine
i turn the computer on and then i go
make myself a cup of tea
i sit down i check my email i send some
messages i respond to some messages
then i do a bit of photoshop work and
some miscellaneous other work
it takes a while to do that so at this
point a couple hours of fast and
honestly aside from not being able to
check slack
like my day is relatively
normal full of the same tasks as i'd be
doing just
slower the one big exception here though
is that so far this week i haven't had
to edit any videos
so we'll see how that goes so i asked
some of my friends and co-workers
to send me pictures for desktop
wallpapers
and i only got one
that's gonna get me through this i'm
trying to photoshop something but it's
just
so bright i'm not gonna get anything
done like this with the sun
ah usually in a situation like this i
would just
take my laptop and i go work on the
couch or if i'm working on my desktop my
screens are
actually bright enough that i can still
see them but i cannot see
what's on the screen it's too dim the
sun has gone down so i can actually work
i'm a productive person i promise don't
fire me
i realize that doing this i actually
like don't know what's going on in the
world so i'm gonna do something i don't
think i've
ever done before i'm gonna buy a
newspaper
apparently there's a presidential debate
tonight you should probably have known
that
i have a meeting in 15 minutes that i
kind of need to
see the screen for um because they're
gonna be sharing a presentation
i don't know how i'm gonna join that i
don't think i can
let's see
meat doesn't work on your browser i
might have to have someone send me the
slides afterwards
if i can't figure out how to join this
meeting i'm actually going to be in big
trouble
i don't want to get fired like this is
not good
thank god mike sent me these phone
numbers beforehand
weird not being able to see your faces
i'm not i don't usually join a call like
this but
my circumstances of using this old
computer for the week
call for it uh if one of you could just
send me the slides that would be
amazing thank you so much no i really
appreciate
it thank you that actually went all
right i appreciate working somewhere
where people are
understanding the stupid things that i'm
doing
i have a little break now which means i
can get to the real reason i bought the
newspaper
across for it what can i say i gotta
have something to do in here
[Music]
spending the day in a bookstore that's a
fun thing to do and you don't need the
internet for it
at the bookstore earlier i decided to
buy this copy of ratatouille so that i
could see if i could watch it on this
computer
i've been craving watching a movie why
not watch ratatouille
[Music]
i love ratatouille i was honestly not so
bad watching a movie like that like i
guess i was a little uncomfortable just
sitting in my chair but like
not so bad
for the first time in a really long time
i stayed up until like
three in the morning reading last night
which was kind of nice
i haven't gotten that engrossed in my
book in a while and i think that has
something to do with the
fact that i have other things to
distract me
it's actually been relatively easy to
find things to do on the weekends
because on the weekdays
usually after i'm done work i kind of
just want to relax and veg out
but on the weekends i want to do stuff
and so i find it a lot easier to not
be on my computer or be on my phone
because i have other things going on
like making hot apple cider
which has been really nice i've read a
lot today i played some music
i walked around i went thrift shopping
overall
pretty good day and i haven't touched
tick tock once
today is the day i've been dreading
because today
is the day that i have to edit a video
on it not a whole video
but i have to do a little bit of editing
so i tried installing a bunch of
different versions of final cut
a few versions of premiere even some
avid versions
couldn't get any of them working but i
finally got a version of
imovie working it's a video editing
software
let's try that clip i could have
predicted this one single clip is larger
than
imovie supports thankfully i did prepare
for this eventuality
and i actually filmed some footage and
converted it last week to
something that this computer may be able
to handle just to see if i can
physically edit on this
oh gorgeous it's a bit slow but it isn't
working i won't make you sit here and
watch me edit
enjoy the final product
so i am finally free of my best friend
for the past week
i'm really happy to be done but i'm also
really glad that i did this i thought i
was going to have difficulty
disconnecting from social media finding
things to do in my free time but
those actually didn't really turn out to
be problems what turned out to be a
problem was not being able to do my job
technology and computers have gotten a
lot better in the last 20 years and i
think we kind of take that
for granted really though this week
reminded me
how much time i do spend on my phone and
i think that going forward i'm just
gonna have to be
more aware of how i'm using my devices
and strike a new balance of how much i'm
using them but now
i'm gonna check instagram for the first
time in a week
for notifications
[Music]
you